It's time to implement the redlines
for the main activity.
We can do one part together
so that you get the hang of it.
We begin by styling
the list item Forecast Layout.
The redline specifies that the image
should be 32dp by 32dp.
We could hard code the image view
to be 32 by 32dp,
but it's actually the same as leaving it
as wrapped content for height and width.
To know what the icon size
would be if we wrap content,
we open up the MDPI version of the icon,
and we do verify that
it is 32 pixels by 32 pixels.
Whether we hard code it
or just add wrap content,
visually, the image
will still look the same,
but in the future
it will be more flexible
if we just specify wrap content
in case the image size changes.
Next we style the text.
On Ice Cream Sandwich and above,
Roboto is the default font for text views.
It is created specifically
to satisfy the requirements of UI
and to optimize for high density screens.
The redline indicates that the font family
is Roboto sans serif condensed,
so we add that to the code.
On the topic of font sizes,
having too many font sizes in your app,
can confuse your user
about the visual hierarchy of your app,
as to what's important
and what's not important.
The Android design guide
recommends these four type sizes
for consistency with a platform
and for user experience.
In our app, we stick to
the standard type sizes.
Unless it's an intentional part of the design,
such as the large temperature values.
Hence, when the redline says
that the date text
should be 22sp for font size,
we could specify
Android text size to be 22sp,
but the text appearance large attribute
already maps to that value.
Note that the font sizes
are specified in sp, and not dp.
Sp stands for scaled pixels, so you can
scale with the device font size.
In our app we specify
text appearance large,
and text appearance small,
which will give us
22sp and 14sp respectively.
The default font color is black,
so we don't need to specify
the android text color attribute
on our text views.
Let's look at the spacing for the
elements within the list item now.
We have three children.
The first one is 60dp wide,
with the image centered inside of it.
So we can add a frame layout
around the image view
and set the gravity
to be center on the image,
that way the image centers itself
within the parent.
For the other two columns,
we shouldn't hard code
such high dp values.
Because otherwise the layout
won't scale across other devices.
Instead, we can use
linear layout weights,
with the weight of seven here,
and the weight of five.
We just tried different values
until we got approximately equal
to these values.
The trick in doing redlines is that
you want to match the visual specs,
but you also want to be
flexible in the code,
so that it adapts
to different screen sizes.
And this is what the code looks like
for the list_items_forecast layout.
We have a horizontal linear layout,
containing the frame layout
with the image view.
Then we have a vertical
linear layout with weight seven.
And then we have another
vertical linear layout with weight five.
We can check the link below
for the full code file.
This is what it should look like
when you're done.
These items looks polished
but we haven't gotten
to the today item yet.